ah
a
[Música]
la primera vez que me encontré con sus
ojos
ambos mirábamos a través del exhibidor
lo que veía me hizo sentir triste
enojada decepcionada en el techo cemento
y unos barrotes paredes con restos de
humedad en el piso paja cristales sucios
al centro una estructura metálica
semejando un árbol nada de lo que veía
era natural excepto a toto un orangután
originario de los bosques tropicales
cautivo en uno de los zoológicos de la
ciudad de mexico la historia de todo es
particular porque cada cuanto tenemos la
oportunidad de conocer a un orangután
digo estos animales son originarios de
indonesia son arbóreos es decir que
necesitan estar en constante movimiento
a través de los árboles con sus brazos y
todos los días hacen nidos a modo de
camas para poder descansar
pero no todo él es un orangután que
nació en cautiverio
la versión oficial es que su madre lo
rechazo a él ya su hermano giambi un año
mayor por lo que tuvieron que ser
criados por seres humanos lo dejo más
claro de manera imprudente los criaron
en un ambiente más apto para un bebé
humano que para una cría de primate
todo y ya me crecieron por ende sus
necesidades también era una columna de
periódico su madre adoptiva maría elena
o yo cuenta como escondía giambi tomó
las llaves del coche logró encenderlo y
avanzar lo por la calle es claro que no
son animales que puedas mantener en tu
casa así que lo más sencillo fue
regresar los a los exhibidores del
zoológico y al ser tan inquietos les
colocaron barrotes en el techo para que
no pudieran escapar
la jaula que los vio nacer se convirtió
en su hogar por 27 años todo creció se
desarrolló y se convirtió en un animal
que le gusta mirar a la gente que se
encuentra del otro lado del exhibidor
cuando las personas se acercan a él se
refieren a él de manera despectiva como
cara de plato por la forma pronunciada
de sus cachetes otros más se asombran
cuando él se acerca coloca sus manos
sobre el cristal y con sus ojos presta
atención a aquellos que lo observan
cuando miramos a los ojos a un animal de
zoológico no es difícil imaginar cómo
han sido sus vidas no importa si eres un
león una jirafa un papión sagrado tu
exibidor va a ser más o menos el mismo
contarás con un cristal piso de tierra o
cemento y en la pared una pintura del
cómo luce tu hábitat natural si eres un
mono o ave tendrás malla a tu alrededor
para que no puedas escapar
si lo intentas un poco más encontrarás
puntos electrificados cada aspecto de tu
vida estará controlado lo que comes a
qué hora lo haces los individuos con los
que convives con quién te reproduces los
pasos que das
los que no das
la gente golpea el cristal gritara
querrá despertarte por supuesto vinieron
a ver animales despertaron temprano se
pusieron ropa cómoda compraron el gorro
de changuitos se pintaron la cara de
elefante y cuando llegan al exhibidor el
elefante apenas y se mueve
los primates parecen estresados
el jaguar está obeso
yo no sé por qué no se mueven si saben
que los venimos a ver preguntaba una
persona hace algunos años en chapultepec
mamá este animal está muerto o porque no
se mueve decía un niño frente a las
jirafas
para el filósofo john berger el
significado que subyace a estas
preguntas es porque estos animales no
están respondiendo a mis expectativas
es difícil enfrentarnos frente a estos
cuestionamientos porque habría de estar
mal en un lugar que nos ofrece helados
hamburguesas y juegos infantiles
animales como nunca los has visto ven y
conoce chimpancés en la ciudad tigres de
sumatra en el asfalto
animales de las selvas en cuartos
viene alimenta los después de esta
fotografía uno de los venados se tragó
la bolsa de plástico donde viene el
alimento que se compra para dárselos el
cuidador me dijo que no me preocupara
que para ellos era como mascar chicle
ante mi insistencia trato de sacársela
pero era demasiado tarde el venado ya se
había tragado el plástico de unos 15
centímetros lo cual pudo haberle
provocado asfixia o algún problema
digestivo
es que tenemos animales complejos con
vidas complejas en exhibidores sencillos
que estamos aprendiendo de estas
instituciones con su modelo actual sobre
los animales al parecer está bien tener
a un orangután de los bosques tropicales
en una ciudad curioso porque orangután
el malayo significa hombre de la selva
no hombre del asfalto
como nos hemos relacionado con los demás
animales nos desplazamos de territorios
que antes les pertenecían convertimos
esos ecosistemas en ciudades y luego los
trajimos de vuelta pero ahora sujetos a
espacios artificiales y a costa de su
dignidad
tenemos que reconocer que los zoológicos
no son para los animales son para
nosotros
y exhibirlos privarlos de su libertad
lejos de ofrecernos una función
educativa nos recuerda nuestro lugar en
la naturaleza los animales en las jaulas
y los seres humanos en una posición
privilegiada
qué pasaría si en lugar de ver a estos
animales como nuestra diversión de
domingo comenzamos a verlos como seres
cuyas vidas importan por sí mismas que
tienen derecho a una vida digna y que en
el contexto de la extinción que los
acecha merecen más
en un cuarto de concreto
que en lugar de apostar por un
cautiverio permanente apostamos por uno
de transición en el cual pudieran ser
rehabilitados y así poder ser llevados a
santuarios áreas naturales protegidas no
se incluso hábitats libres tendríamos
animales siendo animales no bosquejos de
ellos
cuanto le robamos a estos seres por
considerarlos un recurso educativo o de
entretenimiento
este orangután
luce como uno
pero no lo es
no sabe acicalarse hacer nidos
ni moverse por los árboles
el hermano de todo giambi falleció en el
2015 las autoridades se negaron a
brindarle a estos hermanos una
oportunidad de ser llevados a un
santuario para grandes simios dijeron
que estaban en perfecto estado de salud
un mes después la necropsia de giambi
reveló que él estaba enfermo de
leptospira una enfermedad que le
ocasionó un daño renal hepático y
cardiaco
en 23 años he tenido la oportunidad de
aprender de conocer de vivir en el mismo
tiempo el pasado y presente de todo ha
sido exactamente el mismo
la esperanza de vida de los orangutanes
en cautiverio es de 40 años no sé
cuántos años más vaya a vivir este
orangután honestamente no sé cuántos
animales más vayan a morir en
condiciones poco claras y con
enfermedades que se pudieron haber
tratado pero deseo que más gente se una
que se atrevan a contar sus historias
así tal vez las vidas de estos animales
dejen de ser las mismas cada día cada
mes cada año
tal vez finalmente el tiempo de estos
animales ya no sea robado gracias
[Aplausos]